la question dont des statues ou des
monuments en casting ne peut pas avoir
que des statues ça peut être aussi une
réflexion sur la manière de représenter
dans l'espace public
un autre récit ça peut être des fresques
j'en sais rien je ne suis pas
nécessairement fixé sur la question que
ce statut doit être une question
collective et nous et on doit entendre
les voix de ces personnes qui comme
léonora miano le fait remarquer c'est
elles qui font scandale
c'est pas la demande de remplacement de
statut quand on a demandé de remplacer
l'institution demande est là un saint la
statue de pétain ça n'aurait pas
provoqué une controverse et je le répète
je suis sûr que si on demandait de
déplacer la statue de faidherbe pour la
remplacer par simone veil ou simone de
beauvoir on peut importe ça n'aurait pas
cette controverse ce qu'il fait
contreverse c'est que c'est ça fait
partie du combat antiraciste et que de
dire que ces statues contribuent par
leur présence à quelques a effectivement
à la permanence et la maintenance d'un
racisme structurel la fracture elle
existe elle n'est pas du tout amené par
ses mouvements
ce n'est pas parce qu'il ya une
manifestation devant la statue de
gallieni qui la fracture dans la société
française la société française avec
fracture et qui est mort qui manifestent
dans la rue ce sont les soignants qui
étaient là au premier plan au premier
rang pendant la crise je ne vois pas où
en quoi les mouvements les quelques
mouvements qui demande sa fracture et je
voudrais qu'on arrête de nous parler
d'anglo saxons et d' américanisation
nous sommes absolument capables de
penser par nous-mêmes nous écrivant des
livres
nous faisons des études nous étudions
toutes les choses dont crayons des
associations nous examinons comment les
as peuvent être des colonisés nous avons
des artistes avec nous nous avons des
écrivains avec nous ne sommes pas juste
une bande de marginaux qui ne savons pas
ce que nous faisons nous avons pensé
nous travaillons nous partons de nous
mêmes nous partons que des choses de
dire ça ne peut pas se faire sans nous
ce qui se fait sans nous comme des
seuils nelson mandela se fait contre
nous
[Musique]